こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん僕は今までいろんな人の眠りを妨げてきました眠りを
妨げる方法としてはもちろんいろんな方法があると思うんですけども僕基本的に音を
使って眠りを妨げてきますね今回もを頭使って眠りを妨げると思うんですけども
もうねーぞと中でここまで来るとこの特殊な夫とかを探すのは難しくて
もうたぶんねぶっちゃけドラとかねぇドラとかなど
ドラダはドラッグのも最強入れたかったのかなと思ってきたんですけどまぁあの手この
手でいろいろ考えた挙句僕が発明したこれまでておそらくなんですけども一番でかいお
とう
今日はだしてみようと思います準備するものはこちら
th
ハマーそしてこちら来館っていうのかな音花火の意思だと思うんですけどもう10秒
隠遁
バーンてやる奴の回復の部分にあたりますひとつ車庫入れなどでそれを交互でこちらに
10歩先発準備させていただきました
ない版でた時に僕思ったんですけどもあれ実は誰だね大重農的になるこういうのがあっ
てそれではい火薬を置いたところに来たんでこの繰り返し
9のでもバーンちゃってるだけなんですよ意外と単純ねサーの運動家の量移動
運動家の良い土こいつに向かってこなきゃヘッド式がで弾いたパーンってなってるだけ
なんでバーン
これでバーンやればもっとってなるんじゃないんですがねって結論に至ったので全ての
スケールを大きくして今回はアーマードせっこれなるべくこの来館を前頭ぶつけるだけ
つけまくてんてーの
おっ
どうカーン
いいえつけてきますけっこうこれやばいと思うんだけどなぁ食べてねちょっと1個で
やってみましょうか
1個とだいたいこんなことですいきます
ええええええ
あれ立ってる音だーっパパは待って煙ずつじゃあ熱々焦げちゃった
ソレコレハナリカ行きます行きますよこうやると
少ないもんだのジャッジできます
持った
[音楽]
ん
ひとまず重ねまくってなるベガをと花火が一気に出るような状況を作ってあげます
[音楽]
決定したさこれで500発入り
知っていきましたこれで500公約でこれを個々に設定します
よしこれつけます
[音楽]
ジャンプって
ええええええん
はっはっは
[笑い]
というわけで完成しましたまあガーンまあみたいなところでしょ安全にガンハンマー
そんな詐欺っぽい音が鳴る事花火が先発今セットされております近づいて多分耳が守っ
てくれるちょっと離れたぐらいに家で懇願半まで
したて寝てる奴を起こしてあげると思います
ではいこ
[音楽]
voodoo
はぁ
[音楽]
me
dea
car
ana あああっ
おはようああ
ねぇいやいや破壊力4本とエロとどうぞ
今まで家がなければ誰スマートでもいやたぶん彼が最高のパワーだっくみっ
なぁ
マネしないでねやっぱいいああ
患者グッズをする